welcome everyone for our session today
I'm gonna talk about what we've been
working on in Google networking to
increase speed reliability the locations
you can connect to us and of course how
to manage those connections we'll also
cover our recently announced partnership
with Cisco bringing together sd-1 and
the best of DCP cloud starting with our
dedicated interconnect product at next
2019 last year we announced beta
availability for the hundred gigabit per
second dedicated interconnect since then
it's become generally available a
hundred gigabits per second dedicated
interconnect provides 10 times the
capacity of our previous interconnect
offering and can be combined into link
aggregation groups to bring massive
amounts of bandwidth with 100 gigabit
per second dedicated interconnect you
can scale your connection capacity to
meet your particular requirements
connect up to 800 and support circuits
to for private cloud traffic to Google
Cloud at any of our pubs we're also
working on increasing packet per second
performance and making it easier to
achieve high SLA configurations there
will be more news on this later this
year although Google already has
enormous footprint we want to make it
easier and less expensive than ever for
customers to connect to GCP globally so
we're aiming to bring interconnect to
over 30 more locations worldwide by mid
next year when we're done with the
expansion program we'll have brought the
number of locations you can connect to
GCP to well over a hundred adding 50
more look 50% more locations in key
places like Houston Boston Berlin
Canberra and multiple locations in Asia
and the Middle East
finding a suitable location for you to
connect to Google is made easier through
our extensive partner ecosystem you can
now find the optimum connectivity
pathway to Google cloud platform from
any on-net building or data center
worldwide on the new cod pathfinder app
for Google cloud provided by cloud scene
by enabling customers like you with an
app like cloud pathfinder for Google
Cloud we've provided a search based
interface to make it easy to identify
which partners can provide interconnect
connectivity at points closest to your
from to GCP the app is available from
all mobile devices or your desktop you
can access the app for free now via find
dot cloud slash Google moving on to our
cloud VPN product if your needs are to
securely connect everywhere you can use
GCPs klog VPN our newest offering high
availability VPN became generally
available in q4 of last year with hav PN
you can connect to your on-premises GCP
or other cloud environments with an
industry-leading
SLA of four 9s catered for your mission
critical workloads with redundant tunnel
pairs the extra nine takes you from 8
hours and 46 minutes of allowed downtime
per year to just 53 minutes
that's a 90% reduction in allowed
downtime we're encouraging customers to
migrate their deployments from classic
to hav PN to achieve a more reliable
architecture we've briefly covered
Google's Network and the work we've done
to expand the locations to connect
increasing the speed and making your
connections secure and available now
we'd like to zoom out a bit and to end
talk about not just connecting to GCP
but the ability to connect to places
outside of GCP using Google's backbone
and we're doing this initially in
partnership with Cisco here's a little
video that shares a little bit more
about the partnership we've been working
on with Cisco the network is the
foundation of hybrid and multi cloud
business transformation you need a
turnkey solution to securely bridge
applications to networks across multiple
clouds modernize your enterprise and
reduce networking complexity with the
best of Cisco and Google cloud our joint
solution will automatically provision a
reliable global network that grows with
your needs experience simple and
flexible customer network access publish
all of your services in one place and
seamlessly extend intent to enterprise
applications deliver context-aware and
identity based security management
realize a fully software-defined
end-to-end Network get to know Cisco SD
when cloud hub with Google cloud so what
we know is that customers are
increasingly moving into the
of a multi-cloud world many surveys of
enterprise customers suggest that
enterprises are deploying their
applications increasingly across
multiple clouds we believe that this is
the enterprise modernization and digital
transformation journey and it starts
with the network which must enable agile
access to innovation promised by cloud
as well as simplified models for multi
cloud multi platform deployments the
network must evolve to provide agility
simplicity and openness that is needed
to power this transformation to
summarize what we're seeing is
enterprises that are broadly looking to
create connect and consume resources
across a number of different
environments creating them leveraging
the best-in-class technologies
connecting them from a single point and
consuming them on demand including the
connectivity between them when
deployment span multiple app
environments enterprises need to
maintain a fairly precise set of
controls the joint solution from Cisco
and Google addresses exactly these needs
bringing the best of Sdn together with
the intelligence of cloud in order to
enhance application performance and
end-user experience what we're
continuing to see is a shift from
monolithic architectures of legacy apps
on private on Prem data center
environments to a micro services
architecture that are developed that are
deployed in and across clouds where
we're also seeing an increase in the use
of top tier sales applications becoming
more central to maintaining enterprise
productivity the use of sd1 in concert
with cloud network and intelligence
across these environments means that
corporate policies and security postures
can be maintained even as the
application delivery footprint changes
to further joint interests Google and
Cisco are expanding our partnership
through a unique solution called Cisco
SD Wan cloud hub with Google Cloud we
will enable 200,000 enterprises to
access the power of Cisco's sd1 solution
extending it to GCPs Club while powering
connectivity over Google's network
supporting new capabilities such as
allowing enterprises to use Google's
global network as if it were their own
we've seen a number of publications
already begin to detail the power and
potential of the cloud absolution a
Cisco and Google integrate SD LAN and
cloud to deliver a unique value to
customers a few of those publications
and quotes have been shared on this
slide at a high level with the cloud hub
solution enterprise's can continue to
deploy their Cisco Sdn footprint on Prem
and via the Cisco be managed solution
extended to through and within GCP
leveraging Google's network to enhance
connectivity to things like their B PC
environment third party says services
and solutions and other clouds here we
see three major pillars of benefits for
the cloud hub solution related to
flexibility and simplicity improve
end-user experience and risk and
compliance management with the cloud hub
solution connectivity from on Prem to
the cloud hub is provisioned in an
automated fashion via Cisco's be managed
controller while capacity to the cloud
hub is provided on demand as well as
beyond the cloud hub and how the cloud
hub accesses resources that's it on
cloud and beyond
Cisco cloud hub essentially enables
elastic and dynamic consumption of
bandwidth over Google's network with
service directory applications can then
be listed and habits metadata shared
with the Sdn fabric so that the
appropriate delivery treatment can be
provided via the sd1 for each
application specifically also from a
security perspective cisco and google
share the user context to enhance the
ability for the sd1 to maintain the
appropriate levels of access to cloud
apps and services for example sharing
such context would allow access to be
blocked for a user connected to a guest
network within a corporate environment
while accepting access to apps running
on cloud for legitimate corporate users
going into the solution components
specifically Cisco establishes a
presence in Google at the relevant
regions based on the customers
deployment needs from there the cloud
hub solution can leverage Google's
network to connect to other cloud hubs
transit and hybrid connectivity but
cloud hubs will also be able to access
the customers VPC environments and
various applications and services that
are relevant to the customer
speaking of applications and services
enterprises can leverage service
directory through cloud hub in order to
access a catalog and publish a list of
apps and their properties like the need
for low latency transmission to the end
user from here Cisco's V managed
retrieves this information shared via
metadata on a Kerr allocation basis and
then enables the cloud hubs to take the
appropriate traffic steering decisions
based on what's required for a given
application lastly with the Cisco Cloud
hub and Google Cloud Sdn they share
contextual access to corporate user and
app identity to be able to provide
enhanced access to the most secure
segments of the enterprise network to
better manage risk and maintain
compliance to summarize Google and Cisco
are in a strategic collaboration to
build what we believe will be the
industry's first application centric
multi cloud fabric we believe this will
help change the model by which
enterprises choose to connect to the
resources that matter to them the most
in this solution Google provides
reliable connectivity over its network
bridging the enterprise network to cloud
applications and services on GCP and
beyond thank you